si vous en doutez, demandez simplement à l'
équipe de France de football qui vient de remporter la Coupe du
monde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il a poursuivi en disant que la division politique
basée sur la couleur est entièrement artificielle
et quand elle disparaîtra, la
domination d'un groupe de couleur par un autre
qui est  Nelson Mandela parlant en 1964
quand j'avais trois ans ce qui était vrai
alors reste vrai aujourd'hui les vérités fondamentales
ne changent pas c'est une vérité qui peut être
embrassée par les anglais et par les
indiens par les mexicains par les bantous et par
les looool et par les  américain c'est une
vérité qui se trouve au cœur de chaque
religion du monde que nous devrions faire aux
autres ce que nous voudrions qu'ils nous fassent que
nous nous voyons dans les autres que nous
pouvons reconnaître des espoirs communs et des
rêves communs et c'est une vérité  qui est
incompatible avec toute forme de
discrimination fondée sur la race, la religion, le
sexe ou l'orientation sexuelle et
c'est une vérité qui, soit dit en passant, lorsqu'elle est adoptée,
offre en fait des avantages pratiques
puisqu'elle garantit qu'une société peut  n
puiser dans les talents, l'énergie et les compétences de
tous ses habitants et si vous en doutez,
demandez simplement à l'équipe de France de football qui
vient de remporter la Coupe du monde,
car tous ces gens ne ressemblent pas tous à
des balles pour moi, laissez
les Français le  Musique française]